Five, four, three, two, one.
I'm going to Aruba.
(playful music)
- [Interviewer] Do you like cake?
I love cake.
- [Interviewer] Do you like fruits?
Yeah, but
for a snack today the
oranges weren't as good,
but I like fruit.
- [Interviewer] Have you
heard of a fruitcake before?
No.
- [Interviewer] What do you
think they're made out of?
Strawberries, raspberries,
and blueberries.
- [Interviewer] Are you
excited to try them?
I'm very excited.
No (laughs).
- [Interviewer] Why?
Because it might have
crickets (crickets chirping).
(playful music)
(breathing excitedly)
- [Interviewer] What
does it look like to you?
A big mole of dirt.
It smells like a blueberry
pancake and strawberry.
I don't know, I'm gonna
try not to get the fruit.
Blast off into space, mm!
(gags) Nope, nope.
Ew (spits out cake).
Mm!
Tasty, yummy,
and makes my
belly feel
super
happy.
(playful music)
It's not the same thing.
- [Interviewer] This
is apples and cinnamon.
Mm, sounds good.
- [Interviewer] Do you think
you're gonna like this one?
Yes I hope.
It smells like cinnamon of course.
Actually looks like
brownie with apples in it.
Just take a piece.
That was good.
Tasty!
Mm!
Not too bad.
- [Interviewer] It's that good?
Would you eat more?
No.
(playful music)
This one looks like bananas, or peach.
- [Interviewer] So this
is actually a pineapple
macadamia nut fruitcake.
That doesn't sound so good.
Do like pineapple sometimes,
but sometimes they're just too sour.
It reminds me of being at a party.
The smell is gross,
but I bet I'll like it.
Mm.
Good.
- [Interviewer] How good?
Just good.
No, I don't want that.
(spits out fruitcake)
- [Interviewer] What did it taste like?
Rotten gum.
- [Interviewer] So did
you like those fruitcakes?
Yeah a little.
I would love to eat more.
- [Interviewer] Why did
you like those fruitcakes?
Cuz they were delicious.
I liked the apple cinnamon one.
I loved the pineapple
fruitcake cuz it was so good.
- [Interviewer] So would
you eat more of that?
No, why would I eat more of anything?
I would,
if my mom would bake it.
- [Interviewer] So if you
could buy a fruitcake,
who would you buy it for?
Grandma.
- [Interviewer] Why?
Cuz she's that kind of person.
- [Interviewer] What
kind of person is she?
- [Blonde Boy] Old.